what's going on guys this is rob and
after looking at our analytics on the
trailer breakdown we did for the matrix
four you guys really seem to like it so
we're gonna try our hand at some more
matrix content to see whether or not you
guys care and so this video is basically
gonna be a theory video which i think is
really
really cool
which is actually based on a really old
theory from the matrix films so the
first thing i want to specify here is
this theory was not thought up by me
right this theory was actually thought
up by somebody else and i want to make
sure that credit is given adequately and
the theory came from somebody named
tempus on reddit who proposed the idea
of the matrix within a matrix but
building on that theory now those are
the guys who have been a fan of the
matrix series for a long long time you
guys know this theory is not new and in
fact it's been around since the matrix
two right the idea that everybody's kind
of experiencing what is in effect mass
hallucination right that the the whole
idea of zion and all that kind of stuff
that it's all just a matrix within a
matrix and that morpheus and trinity and
neo and seemingly everybody that we saw
is all part of this great big ruse
that's being perpetrated by the machines
now the third film blew that out of the
water right because the third film gave
us what was in effect the real world so
it basically said yes what you're seeing
is tangibly real what you're seeing is
actually happening here's a cool thing
what if it's not right now for those of
you guys who aren't really familiar with
the matrix to give you guys a super
stripped down explanation here the
matrix is basically a film series based
on the idea that a war broke out between
man and machine machine one and then
humans were turned into basically an
energy source right and so humans are
grown they're not really born anymore
they're grown by machines to be plugged
into what is an effect a mainframe and
then their energy is just kind of
siphoned off as humans grow right as we
go from a baby into an adult when we die
we're basically liquefied and fed to the
rest of the human race and the whole
system kind of propagates itself and
that the way in which machines keep
humanity subdued is by using the matrix
a computer generated computer system
basically that simulates the real world
it had gone through different iterations
and in fact it's described that way in
the first movie that they had gone
through different versions of the matrix
a kind of perfect utopia that humanity
rejected because it was too perfect and
so they had to create a world that was
kind of a blend between chaos and
harmony and then only at that point did
humanity actually accept it as basically
being real now for an explanation beyond
that i invite you guys to check out our
video where we did our trailer breakdown
and we basically explained how all that
came to be how the war unfolded the
significance of neo as the one and all
that kind of good stuff but here's where
the theory comes into play and it's
really cool here so as you guys know in
the matrix series neo was just a guy
right that ultimately ended up coming
into contact with morpheus due to a
series of events and that by way of
those series of events he was woken up
to the real world that machines had
basically conquered the world that
humanity was subservient to the machines
being used as an energy source and
because of his role as the one he was
destined to liberate humanity from the
oppression of the machines the side plot
to all this was agent smith who was
basically a computer algorithm designed
to ensure that people basically stay
within their lane so to speak in the
sense that if they wake up from the
matrix they're basically removed right
they're kind of dealt with killed off if
that's what you want to call it they're
kind of like the police force really
more than anything else and that
basically agent smith ended up running
awry after being initially defeated by
neo freed from its programming and then
turned into what was essentially a virus
right and so neo basically had to team
up with the machines in order to destroy
agent smith and then keep the matrix
from falling apart the cool thing about
this theory is this it put forward this
idea that whenever a person starts to
wake up from the matrix which is to say
they start to question their reality
that the matrix basically initiates a
kind of response to this right so if we
use the example of neo that when the
movie began to open up that neo was
questioning his reality he didn't quite
know what he was questioning he didn't
understand how deep it all went but he
was looking things up like what is the
matrix who is morpheus different things
along those lines and so ultimately he
was set on a path right follow the white
rabbit all that kind of stuff and ended
up coming into contact with morpheus at
that point he was presented with the
blue or the red pill the blue pill would
allow him to basically go back to sleep
wake up and forget everything that
happened the red pill would have him
actually wake up into the real world and
the rest of the series unfolded the way
that it did the theory puts forward this
idea that that's a test generated by the
matrix that whenever a person begins to
wake up from the reality or begins to
question the the reality that they're in
essentially believing that they're not
in the real world that the matrix
automatically sends them into a kind of
test right and that everything that goes
on there the idea of morpheus existing
trinity that kind of information out
there is designed as almost kind of like
a lure will somebody catch that and will
they dig further into it the more they
dig into it the more they'll begin to
question the nature of the matrix now we
know not everybody does that and in fact
morpheus told us most people don't that
most people just kind of want to exist
right they just want to stay within the
matrix because it's what they're the
most comfortable with and so in effect
this theory says that from the time that
neo took the red pill until the time he
died none of it actually happened that
instead when he took the red pill it was
essentially the matrix saying okay so
this person basically doubts the
existence of reality but we can't have
them wake up right we can't have them
deviate away from being an energy source
for us as the machines so we're going to
basically shunt them down into a second
matrix where everything that they see
and everything they experience is
believed to be real so in effect there
is no zion there is no morpheus there is
no trinity there's none of that stuff
everything we saw from the time that neo
took the red pill all the way into the
time that he died was a computer
simulation right which is a complete and
total simulation and that in his mind it
basically happened in real time but in
reality he's just there inside one of
his little pots and just being consumed
as a kind of energy source and that when
the time comes when he quote unquote
dies that either his mind shuts down as
we would expect or he's basically
rebooted right his mind is just kind of
reset and then he just sort of continues
on with his normal life and this seems
to work because if you look at the idea
of the matrix resurrections you don't
see neo as a kid you don't see him as a
child you see him as a full-on adult and
so it makes perfect sense that if this
was an actual tangible theory right this
theory is actually what was going on in
the matrix resurrections that at the end
of the matrix three that the loop has
been closed right the whole story about
the other versions of the one and all
that kind of stuff that it's all
malarkey it's all nonsense designed to
give him a what is an effect a
distraction and to give him a purpose so
that he can fulfill that purpose his
mind won't question whether or not the
matrix is real anymore because he will
have solved that right he will have said
yes the matrix was not real and yes i
saved the day and now i'm done right
there's nothing for me to question
anymore i have completed my goal i've
completed my journey call it a day he
gets rebooted gets reset and just wakes
up in the matrix with essentially false
memories right believing he was a child
raised and all that kind of stuff right
i like that idea i love this idea i
think it works really
really really well
because it would really hit home with
this idea that you would have to believe
that machines are nothing if not
efficient and i have a hard time
believing that the machine empire out
there could not foresee something like
this could not foresee the idea that
somebody would wake up from the matrix
possibly because they actually did
somebody actually did wake up from the
matrix at one point in time we know from
the animatrix that people have kind of
woken up before right like the track
runner the guy who was really really
fast he ended up becoming paralyzed and
then basically broke free from the
control of the matrix and then actually
ran faster than he ever had and then was
just shut down right we don't know
exactly when that takes place in
relation to the first matrix movie but
regardless it's entirely possible people
have actually woken up from the matrix
and so in order to ensure that doesn't
happen in order to ensure that no crops
are lost as the machine would refer to
the humanity as that what they do is
they shuffle them off to a second matrix
so they can live out this whole idea of
them saving the world and they can
fulfill what the mind desires which is
the matrix is not real the matrix is
basically a simulated dream world that
the real world is out there and they can
save the day and they can be the hero
and then it'll close everything off the
mind will be satisfied it's like being
hungry and then eating right once you're
full you're not hungry anymore so you
call it a day right you just leave
that that's it's a great idea i love
this theory so here's what i want from
you guys i want to know what you guys
think down in the comments section right
punch holes in this thing i love it when
you guys punch holes in theories even
though you guys do it even though i
never ask you but you know it's cool i
know you guys are going to anyway
you guys punch holes in my theories you
know
i put theories out there put my feelings
out there and you guys just
punch holes in them
[Music]
sad moment
anyway
[Laughter]
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace
you